we know what happens to the environment
or to World Health
under totalitarian regimes that don't
tell the truth
you can't believe a word they say they
have already made their choice
about their strategy
the only choice we have
is do we appease and accommodate
that strategy
or do we take action now to prevent
conflict I'm concerned the Ukraine
should not be forced into some kind of
unfair settlement by China
and I don't believe we should be giving
China leverage over European Security in
fact we should be fast tracking
Ukraine's entry to Nato and providing
Ukraine with all the weapons they need
to make sure that Russia is pushed out
of their country